Our problem tells us that when
1.125 grams of a liquid
hydrocarbon, CxHy-- so we don't
know how many C's and
H's there are, so it's a mystery
liquid hydrocarbon.
It was burned in an apparatus
like that shown in figure
4-7-- this is the apparatus,
this is our mystery
hydrocarbon getting burned, or
it's combusting with oxygen--
you need oxygen for the
combustion to occur.
So when it burns in this
apparatus, and it burns with
oxygen, it tells us -- and we
have 1.125 of it to start
with-- it tells us that 3.447
grams of carbon dioxide and
1.647 grams of water
were produced.
So let me write that reaction
right there.
So let me just write this first
sentence right here.
Write all of the information
that they're giving us in that
first sentence.
They're saying that when we
start off with that liquid
hydrocarbon that has x C's and
y H's in it, and it's in its
liquid state, they say it's
a liquid hydrocarbon.
And when we combust it using
oxygen in its gaseous state,
we will produce carbon
dioxide and water.
And you can't even really
realistically balance this
equation because you don't
know how many carbons and
hydrogens you have on
the left-hand side.
But what they do tell us is how
many grams of everything,
of at least this we start with,
and how many grams of
each of these we end up with,
and we're assuming that we
have an excess of oxygen.
That this hydrocarbon is
the limiting reactant.
We just have an abundance
of oxygen.
Just enough oxygen to turn all
of this hydrocarbon, to
combust all of it into carbon
dioxide and water.
And they tell us that we have
1.125 grams of the mystery
substance, and then it produces
3.447 grams of carbon
dioxide, and 1.647
grams of water.
Now to solve this-- well let me
finish reading the problem.
It tells in a separate reaction
or in a separate
experiment, the molar mass of
the compound was found to be
86.2 grams per mole.
So I'll write that down here.
So CxHy molar mass is equal to--
let me write it this way
instead just to go with the
convention that I've been
doing-- we have 86.2 grams of
our mystery substance, CxHy
per mole of our mystery
substance, CxHy.
And then they're asking us
in this problem, they say
determine the empirical and
molecular formulas for the
unknown hydrocarbon CxHy.
And just as a refresher,
empirical means just the
simplest whole number ratio of
the atoms in our molecule.
So the simplest ratio of our
carbons to hydrogens, or
hydrogens to carbons, will give
us the empirical formula.
The molecular formula is how
many carbons, exactly how many
carbons and hydrogens do
we have in each atom.
And I suspect we're going
to be able to use this
information to come up, once
we have the empirical
formulation, the empirical
formula, we then can use this
molar mass right here to
figure out the actual
molecular formula.
But let's figure out the
empirical formula first.
And the way we can do it is we
could say, well gee, how many
moles of carbon dioxide
we get produced, how
many moles of hydrogen?
And then we could say, well in
the final product, how many
moles of carbon do
we have then?
And how many moles of hydrogen
do we have there?
And then we can figure
out the ratio.
And the ratio of carbons to
hydrogens or hydrogens to
carbons in the product, that's
going to have to be the same
as the ratio in the reactants.
And they all came from this
reactant right there.
They didn't come
from the water.
And then hopefully we'll be
able to figure out the
simplest whole number ratio
of hydrogens to carbons or
carbons to hydrogens is.
That sounds very complicated I
think, but I think if we take
it step-by-step it
won't be too bad.
So a good place to start, let's
figure out how many
moles of each of these
substances we have. I'll start
off with the carbon dioxide.
So if I start off with the
carbon dioxide, what is the
molar mass of carbon dioxide?
So its atomic weight, carbon is
12 plus you have 2 oxygens,
so 2 times-- the atomic weight
of oxygen is 16, you could
look that up if you like--
but that's equal to
44 atomic mass units.
That's its atomic weight, which
is the weighted average
of all of the isotopes and
all of that business.
But if you have a whole mole of
carbon dioxide, 6.022 times
10 to the 23rd of these
molecules, then you're going
to have 44 grams of
the substance.
So we have 44 grams of
CO2 per mole of CO2.
And if we want to figure out
how many moles we have with
us, we know that we're
starting off with
3.447 grams of CO2.
And we want to multiply this by
something that has grams of
CO2 in the denominator.
So we want to multiply it by
something that looks like
this-- and we want to turn
it into moles of CO2.
So it should have moles of
CO2 over grams of CO2.
Well that's the inverse
of this right here.
This is grams per mole, we
want moles per gram.
So instead of 44 grams per mole,
we have 1 over 44 moles
per gram, or for every 44 grams
we have 1 mole, for
every 1 mole we have 44 grams.
I just inverted this.
So let's multiply.
The grams of CO2 cancel out with
the grams of CO2, and you
are left with 3.447
divided by 44.
So let's figure out
what that is.
So you have 3.447 divided by 44,
which is equal to 0.07834.
So 7-8-3-4.
Let me remember that.
So that is 0.07834 moles
of CO2-- that's
our only units left.
Now let's figure out how many
moles of water we have. So I
could do the exact same thing
over-- let's see,
where should I do that.
Let me write it over here.
So let's do the water in
orange right here.
So we're starting off with
1.647 grams of H2O.
And what is water's
molar mass?
Same argument, its atomic mass
is-- each hydrogen is 1.
But you have 2 of them so it's
2 times 1 plus 16, which is
the atomic weight of oxygen.
So 2 times 1 plus 16 is 18.
That's also its molar mass.
You could say 18 grams of
H2O per mole of H2O.
Now to convert this, the amount
of grams we have to
moles, what we want to do is
multiply it by something that
has moles in the numerator and
grams in the denominator.
We want grams of H2O in the
denominator and moles of H2O
in the numerator.
And that's the exact
inverse of this.
So if we have 18 grams per
mole, we have 1 over
18 moles per gram.
And what is this going
to be equal to?
So this cancels out with that,
so we're left with 1.647
divided by 18 moles of H2O.
Let me scroll over
a little bit.
Get the calculator out.
Clear it out.
And so we have 1.647 divided
by 18, which is 0.0915.
Let me do this in a new color.
We have a 0.0915 moles of H2O.
So so far we figured out in our
products how many moles of
carbon dioxide we have, and
how many moles of water.
Now, I said we want to figure
out the ratio of hydrogens to
carbons or carbons to hydrogens
to figure out the
empirical formula right here.
And to do that we can say hey
look, all of the carbons and
the hydrogens in our products,
they all had to come from our
mystery hydrocarbon.
So if we can figure out the
ratio of hydrogens to carbons
in our products, we'll know
the ratio of hydrogens to
carbons in our reactants.
Because they all had to come
from this guy right here.
The oxygen, obviously, had no
hydrogens and carbons in it.
So all of these hydrogens
and carbons came
from our mystery substance.
So how many moles of
carbon do we have?
How many moles of carbon do we
have in the carbon dioxide, in
our products?
Well the only product with
carbon is the carbon dioxide.
This has no carbon in it.
So if we have this many carbon
dioxides, we also have the
same number of carbon atoms,
moles of atomic carbon.
And you might say hey,
that's just a number.
This is saying 0.07 times 6.022
times 10 to the 23rd
times that huge number.
A mole is just a number-- very
important to remember.
So this means we have the
same number of carbons.
And if we have that many
waters, how many
hydrogens do we have?
Well for every water molecule
we have 2 hydrogens.
So we're going to have twice
as many hydrogen atoms.
So let's multiply
that times 2.
So times 2 is equal to 0.183.
So we have 0.183.
I could even put a trailing 0,
because we actually had-- well
I think I lost the significant
digit here.
I could have put a
zero right there.
But anyway, I won't worry
too much about that.
0.183 moles of atomic hydrogen,
because for every
water molecule we have
2 hydrogens.
So I just took this number
and multiplied by 2.
And now let's figure out the
ratio of hydrogens to carbons,
and that's pretty easy.
We just take a ratio
of that to that.
So the ratio of hydrogens to
carbons is 0.183 moles of
hydrogen in our product for
every 0.07834 moles of the
carbon in our product.
And somehow we have to make this
into some type of a whole
number ratio.
Let's see whether we can
do anything here.
Let's just divide this right
here and see what we get.
So if we just take-- well we
have the 0.183 there, so let's
divide it by 0.07834,
and you get 2.336.
So this is approximately equal
to-- I'll do a new color-- is
approximately equal to 2.336
moles of hydrogen for every 1
mole of carbon.
This doesn't look like that neat
of a ratio, but this is
pretty close to 1/3.
So maybe if we multiply the
numerator and the denominator
by 3 what do we get?
Well 3 times 2 is 6 and 3
times 1/3 is another 1.
So this will be 7.
7 moles of hydrogen.
I'm approximating it.
I'm trying to get to some
reasonable whole number.
7 moles of hydrogen for every
3 moles of carbon.
And this was a little
bit of an art to it.
I said OK, 2.33:1 or 2.336:1,
well gee, this looks like,
over here, this part of it looks
like if we multiplied
that by 3 we're going
to get pretty
close to a whole number.
So let me multiply the
numerator and the
denominator by 3.
That's kind of the art there to
recognize what do you have
to multiply this to turn
it into a whole number.
And if you don't believe me, we
could take that number and
multiply it by 3 and you get
something very, very, very,
very close to 7.
So that's enough for me.
So you're multiplying both by 3,
you get 7 moles of hydrogen
for every 3 moles of carbon.
And we've figured out our
empirical formula.
We have 7 hydrogens for
every 3 carbons.
Right?
If we have 7 moles, for every
3 moles that means we have 7
hydrogens for every 3 carbons.
And so the empirical formula of
our mystery hydrocarbon is
for every 3 carbons we
have 7 hydrogens.
Now the next thing we want
to figure is the
exact molecular formula.
The exact number of-- this is
just the minimum ratio.
But maybe we have 9 carbons
for every 21 hydrogens.
We don't know.
So let's use the other
information they gave us in
the problem where they told us
that the molar mass is 86.2
grams per mole-- this
information right here.
Let me copy that.
86.2-- that looks like
an 80, but we'll
remember it says 86.2.
So let me paste it over here.
That's what they gave
us in the problem.
So just for kicks, what would be
the molar mass if this was
the molecular formula?
So as it's written right now--
well there's a couple of ways.
We could do it algebraically
and all of that.
But the simplest way is to say
as it's written right now what
would be the molecular
mass of this?
Or the molar mass,
I should say.
So it would be 3 times
12, plus 7, times 1.
3 times 12 is 36 plus
7 is equal to 43.
So if this was the molecular
formula, its molecular mass
would be 43 grams per mole.
But they tell us in the problem
that the molecular
mass is 86 grams per mole.
So they're saying that the mass
is twice as much as this.
We must have twice as many
atoms in the same ratio.
So the molecular formula for
this-- we're in the home
stretch now-- the molecular
formula must have twice as
many atoms in the exact
same ratio.
So it must be C3H7 times 2, or
we could write that as C6H14.
So this is still a ratio
of 14:6, which is 7:3.
But using this information, we
were able to figure out the
exact number of carbons and the
exact number of hydrogens
in this molecule.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that fun.